hi nama saya Olivia Lanes dan selamat kembali ke Quantum Computing dalam Praktik ini episod dua Quantum
circuits kita akan bincangkan beberapa topik dalam kuliah hari ni tapi benda yang saya nak korang bawa balik adalah tiga perkara ni satu apa itu komputer IBM
quantum sebenarnya supaya korang sekurang-kurangnya ada gambaran kasar dalam kepala tentang apa yang korang buat bila hantar kerja ke salah satu tu melalui
cloud dua apa itu qubit apa itu Primitives dan macam mana kita boleh guna semua tu untuk cipta dan laksanakan Quantum circuits
kita juga akan bincang secara ringkas tentang jenis-jenis pemproses IBM Quantum yang ada dan apa yang bezakan satu daripada yang lain dan tiga
akhir sekali aliran kerja biasa yang kita ikut untuk jalankan eksperimen secara besar-besaran ini termasuk pilih Primitives terbaik
untuk kes guna korang memetakan masalah ke Quantum circuit dan menerapkan penekanan ralat dan mitigasi yang membolehkan
kita keluarkan kuasa sebanyak mungkin daripada mesin-mesin ni sekarang ada banyak maklumat di sini tapi ikut je dengan saya
sebab tidak lama lagi kita akan gabungkan semua tu dalam konteks beberapa contoh sebenar mula-mula jom kita bincang secara ringkas tentang qubit dan perkakasan Quantum sebenar
sebagai seorang eksperimentalis saya boleh jamin ia sangat menarik dan ia memang membantu untuk menyambungkan semua titik bila
kita bayangkan apa yang sebenarnya berlaku bila kerja dihantar ke komputer quantum melalui cloud pemproses yang
kita nak guna ni dibina dengan superconducting transmon qubit ni la rupa pemproses IBM quantum yang kecil
sekarang kotak-kotak kecil ni ialah qubit itu sendiri jadi ada lima kesemuanya pada cip ni transmon
itu sendiri adalah kapasitor dan ia terdiri daripada dua plat logam yang disambung secara selari dengan peraruh bukan linear yang dipanggil
Josephson junction tapi untuk tengok Josephson junction tu korang sebenarnya kena zum in lagi ia dicipta daripada dua
lapisan logam superconducting yang bertindih dan di mana dua kepingan tu bertindih dan bersentuhan adalah junction tu Josephson
Junction adalah elemen yang boleh digunakan untuk cipta atom tiruan dengan berbilang aras tenaga dan kita asingkan
dua aras tenaga bawah sebagai keadaan Qubit kita garisan bergelombang di sini mewakili resonator gelombang mikro
pada asasnya talian transmisi 2D yang diganding kepada Qubit sekarang bila kita atur cara gate itu pada asasnya sama dengan memilih
denyutan gelombang mikro yang ditentukur dengan tepat dan frekuensi amplitud bentuk dan tempoh denyutan tertentu tu buat
Qubit buat benda tertentu arahan untuk denyutan gelombang mikro pergi dari komputer korang ke cloud dan
kemudian dibaca dan ditafsirkan oleh Elektronik kawalan suhu bilik yang ambil arahan tu dan secara fizikal
hasilkan denyutan tu kita panggil denyutan gelombang mikro sebab semua tu masuk dalam jalur frekuensi gelombang mikro
iaitu sekitar 1 GHz selepas kotak kawalan suhu bilik hasilkan denyutan tu ia bergerak melalui kabel
masuk ke dilution refrigerator dan akhirnya ke cip Quantum kita isyarat masuk ke resonator melalui
wire Bond pada pad ni dan kemudian ia mengalir turun talian transmisi ke qubit kita sekarang saya tahu ini semua mungkin
agak teknikal dan butiran ni tak penting sangat untuk difahami oleh kita ke depan tapi saya harap sekarang
korang semua sekurang-kurangnya boleh bayangkan sistem fizikal yang korang semua nak berinteraksi dengan tu jadi di mana komputer quantum ni
sebenarnya wujud well IBM ada berpuluh-puluh komputer quantum di seluruh dunia dan kita baru-baru ni naik taraf fleet kita
untuk mengandungi hanya pemproses qubit 100 ke atas macam yang saya sebut dalam pelajaran sebelum ni beberapa daripadanya terletak di pusat data IBM
Quantum di Upstate New York sistem-sistem tu disebarkan ke seluruh cloud untuk kegunaan semua orang dan beberapa
daripadanya adalah sistem on premise khusus lengkap dengan semua elektronik untuk membuatnya berfungsi yang menyokong rakan kongsi kita
dalam rangkaian IBM quantum sekarang jom bincang tentang Qiskit iaitu kit pembangunan perisian sumber terbuka IBM
yang direka untuk digunakan pada komputer quantum mulai sekarang saya akan rujuk ini sebagai Qiskit SDK ada juga
ekosistem Qiskit iaitu koleksi tutorial perisian dan fungsi yang dibina atas atau melanjutkan fungsi teras Qiskit serta Qiskit
runtime iaitu perkhidmatan Quantum Computing dan model pengaturcaraan yang membolehkan pengguna mereka bentuk dan secara cekap
laksanakan beban kerja Quantum mereka dengan menggunakan Qiskit Primitives dan Primitive pada asasnya adalah blok binaan kecil yang
boleh korang guna untuk reka circuit yang lebih besar atau kerja dua Primitives yang paling penting bagi kita ialah
sampler dan estimator yang akan kita bincangkan dengan lebih mendalam tidak lama lagi kalau korang belum muat turun dan pasang
Qiskit SDK lagi takde masa yang lebih baik dari sekarang Qiskit 1.0 baru-baru ni dikeluarkan dan ia lebih berprestasi dan
stabil dari sebelumnya jadi bagi korang yang baru nak mula korang datang pada masa yang sesuai bagi korang
yang dah biasa dengan Qiskit korang perlu muat turun dan pasang semula versi terbaru kita cadangkan guna
pip untuk pasang Qiskit dan Qiskit runtime dan jalankan melalui Jupiter notebook dalam pelayar web pilihan korang jadi korang juga perlu
pasang jupyter notebook atau Jupiter lab kalau korang belum buat tu lagi semua alat ni percuma dan korang
boleh jalankan pada mesin tempatan korang sendiri tanpa sebarang kos pastikan tambah Qiskit dengan
pilihan visualization supaya ia berfungsi dengan Jupiter dan bagi korang plot benda korang juga perlu sediakan persekitaran python maya dan ada
arahan cara nak buat ni pada halaman pasang Qiskit yang dipautkan di sini setelah korang biasa dengan Qiskit dan korang
dah sedia nak jalankan kerja pada komputer quantum sebenar korang perlu daftar di quantum.com dan buat token API IBM Quantum
dan ada juga pautan di sini untuk itu panduan lengkap cara nak buat ini ikut semua
arahan dalam halaman dokumentasi kita macam yang saya sebut atau korang boleh tonton video pemasangan coding with Qiskit di sini
kedua-duanya dipautkan dan dalam deskripsi sekarang kita dah hampir nak mula bincang tentang Quantum
circuits memandangkan tujuan kursus ni adalah untuk mengajar korang penonton cara nak skala kerja korang untuk dijalankan pada skala
qubit 100 ke atas saya percaya cara yang paling berguna ke depan adalah dengan mempertimbangkan aliran kerja keseluruhan yang akan kita ikut dan cara paling mudah untuk
faham aliran kerja Quantum Computing biasa adalah melalui Qiskit patterns Qiskit patterns adalah rangka kerja konseptual yang membolehkan pengguna menjalankan
beban kerja Quantum dengan melaksanakan langkah-langkah tertentu dengan alat modular ini membolehkan tugasan Quantum Computing dilakukan oleh
infrastruktur Komputasi heterogen yang berkuasa langkah-langkah ni boleh dilakukan sebagai perkhidmatan dan boleh
menggabungkan Pengurusan Sumber yang membolehkan kebolehgabungan keupayaan baru yang lancar apabila ia dibangunkan di sini
adalah langkah-langkah utama yang pengguna Qiskit berpengalaman mungkin dah kenal pasti langkah pertama adalah pemetaan langkah ini
formalkan cara kita ambil masalah umum yang kita minati dan cari tahu cara memetakannya ke dalam komputer quantum
dalam bentuk circuit seterusnya kita optimumkan dalam langkah ini kita guna Qiskit transpiler untuk laluan dan susun atur
circuit pada Perkakasan Quantum fizikal sebenar ini termasuk menterjemahkan Quantum Gates individu ke dalam urutan
WEBVTT
operasi yang dilakukan pada perkakasan serta pengoptimuman dalam susun atur gates tu seterusnya kita akan
laksanakan Qiskit runtime Primitives menyediakan antara muka ke Perkakasan IBM Quantum yang membolehkan circuit yang telah di-transpile berjalan
langkah ni juga termasuk menggunakan teknik penekanan ralat dan mitigasi yang boleh diabstrakkan sepenuhnya daripada pengguna akhir sekali kita buat post-processing dalam
langkah ni data dari pemproses quantum itu sendiri diproses memberi pengguna hasil yang berguna tentang masalah asal pada asasnya langkah ini
merangkumi sebarang analisis lanjut data yang diperoleh sekarang kita dah sedia nak bincang asas program quantum
iaitu quantum circuits harap korang dah biasa dengan Quantum circuits tapi kalau tak ada baiknya tengok dulu pelajaran
tiga Quantum circuits yang merupakan sebahagian daripada understanding Quantum information and computation yang dipautkan di bawah kita hanya akan
bagi ulasan ringkas di sini sekarang Quantum circuit adalah rangkaian quantum Gates dan pengukuran yang disambungkan
oleh wayar yang mewakili qubit Quantum circuits boleh dibaca seperti nota muzik dari kiri ke kanan bermula pada
Masa Sifar iaitu paling kiri qubit maya bermaksud qubit yang belum lagi diperuntukkan kepada qubit fizikal sebenar
pada pemproses disenaraikan dalam urutan menaik dari atas ke bawah setelah kita sediakan circuit kita boleh tambah
gates padanya gates qubit tunggal seperti Hadamard gate di sini hanya mempengaruhi qubit yang wayarnya diletakkan gates qubit berbilang
seperti cnot ni mempengaruhi dua atau lebih qubit yang disambungkan oleh gate dalam contoh ini keadaan qubit satu berubah
bergantung pada keadaan qubit sifar setelah semua gates digunakan kita boleh lakukan pengukuran
yang menyebabkan keputusan ditulis pada daftar klasikal satu ciri penting khususnya
sesebuah circuit adalah kedalaman depth quantum circuit adalah bilangan minimum lapisan quantum Gates yang dilaksanakan secara
selari yang diperlukan untuk melengkapkan pengiraan yang ditakrifkan oleh circuit tu untuk jelaskan Quantum Gates boleh dilaksanakan secara
selari atau dengan kata lain pada masa yang sama bila mana ia tidak ada qubit yang sama tapi kalau dua atau lebih
gates bertindak pada qubit yang sama kita tak boleh laksanakannya secara selari kita terpaksa laksanakannya satu demi satu sebab Quantum Gates ambil masa untuk
dilaksanakan kedalaman sebuah circuit lebih kurang berpadanan dengan jumlah masa yang diperlukan komputer quantum untuk melaksanakan
circuit tu jadi tahu kedalaman circuit penting untuk tahu sama ada ia boleh digunakan pada peranti tertentu atau tidak ia juga akan memberitahu kita sama ada ia
ada peluang yang baik untuk menghasilkan keputusan yang tepat seterusnya jom beralih ke pemilihan pemproses Quantum IBM
baru-baru ni mengeluarkan fleet pemproses baru semua mempunyai lebih 100 qubit dan korang boleh log masuk ke quantum.com untuk tengok
pemproses mana yang korang ada akses pemproses tu semua dinamakan sempena burung atas sebab tertentu dan logo berbeza
mewakili jenis pemproses berbeza jadi contohnya yang ini mewakili pemproses Eagle dan ikon ini adalah
heron nama pemproses tertentu juga terdapat di bahagian atas semua dinamakan sempena bandar tapi itu
tak semestinya bermaksud pemproses tu secara fizikalnya terletak di bandar tu semua tu hanya nama bilangan qubit
EPPG dan CLOPS juga faktor yang semuanya disenaraikan kita akan terangkan setiap satu ni
qubit sekarang ni cukup jelas qubit adalah bilangan jumlah qubit yang tersedia untuk digunakan pada pemproses Quantum tunggal atau
QPU EPG bermaksud ralat per layered gate yang mengukur ralat proses gate purata dalam rantaian berlapis
100 qubit pada dasarnya korang nak ia sekecil mungkin CLOPS bermaksud circuit layer operations per second dan
ia mengukur berapa banyak lapisan quantum volume circuit iaitu circuit maya yang boleh dilaksanakan QPU setiap unit masa
semakin tinggi nombor semakin cepat kita boleh mengira ini setara dengan apa yang flops bermaksud dalam Komputasi klasikal sekarang
metrik berbeza ni mungkin lebih atau kurang penting bergantung pada kawasan aplikasi tertentu yang korang minati seterusnya jom bincang secara ringkas tentang
pemetaan ke Quantum circuits langkah pertama adalah langkah pemetaan yang pada asasnya menjawab soalan macam mana
saya terjemahkan masalah saya ke Quantum circuit yang boleh dijalankan pada Perkakasan Quantum sekarang tak dinafikan
pemetaan adalah masalah yang susah dan ia adalah kawasan penyelidikan aktif kadang-kadang hanya dapat mengambil masalah pengiraan
dan hasilkan urutan quantum Gates yang membantu menyelesaikannya adalah bahagian yang paling susah takde
kaedah yang pasti berjaya tapi ada garis panduan yang disyorkan dan contoh masalah yang kita dah tahu macam mana nak
petakan garis panduan pertama adalah biarkan komputer klasikal buat apa sahaja kerja yang lebih baik mereka lakukan sendiri ujian
yang mudah bagi komputer klasikal mungkin tak akan mendapat manfaat daripada komputer quantum komputer quantum adalah untuk masalah yang secara klasikal sukar
tentu saja kalau ni pertama kali korang guna Qiskit atau komputer quantum jangan risau tentang mencari masalah yang kompleks secara pengiraan pecahkan ia
kepada masalah yang lebih kecil yang boleh korang belajar untuk tangani sebelum terus ke projek skala utiliti seterusnya terjemahkan
hasil untuk masalah korang yang korang nak ukur atau faham ke dalam masalah nilai jangkaan atau masalah pensampelan
untuk kebanyakan jenis masalah ini pada asasnya berpadanan dengan mengira fungsi kos fungsi kos adalah
fungsi khusus masalah yang mentakrifkan matlamat masalah sebagai sesuatu yang perlu diminimumkan atau dimaksimumkan dan ia boleh
digunakan untuk tengok prestasi keadaan percubaan atau penyelesaian terhadap matlamat tu
konsep ni boleh diterapkan pada pelbagai aplikasi dalam kimia pembelajaran mesin Kewangan pengoptimuman dan sebagainya
juga ingat bahawa perkakasan yang korang nak guna mempunyai topologi tertentu ada qubit yang tak disambungkan
dan ada yang disambungkan dan akhirnya korang perlu petakan masalah korang ke circuit yang mewakili ini pemproses IBM Quantum
menggunakan apa yang dipanggil topologi heavy hex yang pada asasnya bersamaan dengan sambungan qubit dalam kekisi heksagonal yang
akan kita pelajari lebih lanjut kemudian dalam kursus ni buat masa ini perkara paling penting untuk diingat adalah bahawa peringkat ini memerlukan
latihan korang perlu mempunyai pemahaman yang baik bukan sahaja tentang masalah korang tetapi juga tentang keupayaan Perkakasan quantum
dan kita akan melalui contoh dan kes guna tertentu kemudian untuk tengok cara terbaik ia boleh
diseimbangkan sekarang jom bincang cara mengoptimumkan circuit untuk perkakasan yang kita pilih matlamat keseluruhan langkah
pengoptimuman adalah memetakan semua qubit maya dari circuit kita ke qubit sebenar di suatu tempat pada
topologi pemproses nama permainannya adalah untuk kurangkan ralat sebanyak mungkin untuk buat ni kita perlu dulu
lalukan dan susun atur circuit kita dengan cekap perkara pertama yang perlu diingat adalah tidak semua qubit disambungkan macam
yang dah saya katakan ada yang sebenarnya jauh antara satu sama lain pada cip jadi kita perlu kurangkan atau hapuskan interaksi jarak jauh
bila mungkin korang boleh gunakan urutan swap Gates antara qubit jiran untuk menggerakkan maklumat qubit
sekitar tapi swap gates adalah mahal dan terdedah kepada ralat jadi mungkin ada cara yang lebih baik untuk buat ni seterusnya susun atur
WEBVTT
dan laluan adalah proses berulang dan ia memperuntukkan qubit maya dalam circuit korang pada qubit fizikal pada
perkakasan korang boleh buat ni secara manual tapi ada juga alat dalam Qiskit yang boleh buat cadangan untuk susun atur fizikal
qubit berdasarkan kadar ralat anggaran seterusnya kita boleh susun urutan gates qubit tunggal yang bertindak pada qubit yang sama
menjadi gates tunggal dan kita juga kadang-kadang boleh buang gates yang tidak perlu atau kombinasi gates contohnya
beberapa kombinasi gates boleh dikurangkan kepada kombinasi yang lebih mudah dan kadang-kadang kombinasi gates bahkan
bersamaan dengan pengendali identiti mudah jadi kita boleh hapuskan terus korang boleh buat ni secara automatik menggunakan
Qiskit transpiler atau korang boleh buat secara manual atas asas gate demi gate kalau korang ada sebab yang kukuh untuk buat tu dan nak
lebih kawalan setelah kita perbaiki susun atur circuit laluan dan bilangan gate sama ada secara manual atau menggunakan Qiskit transpiler kita
biasanya nak visualisasikan circuit kita untuk pastikan masa semua gates masuk akal ada argumen yang boleh korang tandakan dalam transpiler untuk
visualisasikan garis masa circuit korang dan pastikan semua sudah tersusun seperti yang korang jangkakan sekarang jom bincang tentang penekanan ralat
penekanan ralat merujuk kepada pelbagai teknik yang mengubah circuit semasa penyusunan untuk meminimumkan ralat
ia berbeza daripada mitigasi ralat yang berlaku selepas circuit dah dijalankan dan kita akan sampai ke situ tidak lama lagi dua bentuk paling biasa
penekanan ralat yang kita ambil manfaat daripada adalah dynamical decoupling dan Pauli twirling akan ada sedikit
butiran teknikal di sini tapi korang selalu boleh rujuk balik ke sini kemudian jadi yang pertama dynamical decoupling digunakan untuk
membatalkan sebahagian besar bunyi hingar yang mempengaruhi Qubit dengan menerapkan siri gates yang bersama-sama berjumlah
operasi identiti seperti urutan XX dan kesan bersihnya adalah untuk membatalkan secara anggaran saluran bunyi hingar yang mempengaruhi
qubit Pauli twirling adalah cara memasukkan gates rawak untuk memudahkan bunyi hingar purata rawak tu membantu
mencegah kesan daripada ralat berbeza daripada terkumpul terlalu cepat dan juga menjadikan bunyi hingar lebih mudah dicirikan
sekarang kaedah ni juga membentuk asas teknik mitigasi ralat dan kita akan bincangkan kemudian
sekali lagi ada banyak maklumat di sini dan jangan risau kalau tak semua masuk dalam kepala terus nasib baik banyak daripada ni boleh dilakukan secara automatik menggunakan Qiskit
transpiler transpilation boleh jadi rumit tapi transpilation adalah langkah yang sangat penting untuk mencapai utiliti pada skala besar
sehingga ia memerlukan banyak cubaan dan kesilapan untuk dikuasai dan mendapatkan hasil terbaik sekarang saya nak ambil
selingan singkat untuk bincangkan Qiskit transpiler dan keupayaannya dengan lebih lanjut saya akan buat ini pada peringkat yang sangat tinggi dan kita akan masuk ke butiran dan tengok
beberapa contoh kemudian pada umumnya transpilation adalah proses penulisan semula circuit input yang diberikan untuk padankan
topologi dan peranti Quantum tertentu dan optimumkan circuit untuk pelaksanaan dan ketahanan terhadap bunyi hingar ia juga
menulis semula circuit yang diberikan ke dalam basis gates pemproses Quantum tertentu yang korang pilih untuk guna Qiskit ada empat
saluran paip transpilation terbina dalam dan melainkan korang dah biasa dengan pengoptimuman quantum circuit saya pasti cadangkan guna salah satu daripada tu
secara lalai transpiler merangkumi enam langkah ini permulaan
susun atur laluan terjemahan pengoptimuman dan penjadualan sekarang permulaan merujuk kepada
sebarang laluan awal yang diperlukan sebelum kita mula membenamkan circuit ke backend ini biasanya melibatkan
pembongkaran arahan tersuai dan penukaran circuit hanya kepada gates qubit satu dan dua peringkat susun atur menerapkan
pemetaan susun atur yang memetakan qubit maya dalam circuit ke qubit fizikal pada backend laluan berjalan selepas susun atur telah
diterapkan dan menyuntik gates seperti swap Gates ke dalam circuit asal untuk membuatnya serasi dengan
kesambungan backend peringkat keempat adalah terjemahan dalam peringkat ini gates dalam circuit diterjemahkan ke set basis
backend Sasaran seterusnya adalah pengoptimuman peringkat ini menjalankan gelung pengoptimuman utama
berulang kali sehingga keadaan seperti mencapai kedalaman sasaran tertentu dipenuhi kita ada empat aras pengoptimuman berbeza
yang boleh kita pilih akhir sekali adalah penjadualan peringkat ini untuk sebarang laluan penjadualan peka perkakasan pada
peringkat tinggi penjadualan boleh difikirkan sebagai memasukkan kelewatan ke dalam circuit untuk mengambil kira masa melahu pada qubit
di antara pelaksanaan arahan jadi macam yang saya cakap ada empat aras pengoptimuman dari 0 hingga tiga di mana
aras pengoptimuman yang lebih tinggi mengambil lebih masa dan usaha pengiraan tapi korang mungkin berakhir dengan circuit yang lebih baik
aras pengoptimuman sifar bertujuan untuk eksperimen pencirian peranti dan oleh itu hanya memetakan circuit input ke
kekangan backend sasaran ia tidak melakukan sebarang pengoptimuman aras pengoptimuman tiga
menghabiskan usaha paling banyak untuk optimumkan circuit namun memandangkan banyak teknik pengoptimuman dalam
transpiler adalah berdasarkan heuristik menghabiskan lebih banyak usaha pengiraan tidak selalunya menghasilkan penambahbaikan
dalam kualiti circuit output kalau ini menarik minat korang sila semak halaman transpiler dalam dokumentasi Qiskit
yang dipautkan di bawah sekarang kita dah sedia nak bincang pelaksanaan sebenar Quantum circuit
Qiskit runtime Primitives menyediakan antara muka ke perkakasan IBM Quantum dan ia juga mengabstrakkan penekanan ralat
dan mitigasi daripada pengguna sampler primitive mengembalikan taburan kebarangkalian Kuasi atau kiraan
yang mewakili kebarangkalian mengukur rentetan bit tertentu sifar dan satu estimator primitive mengembalikan nilai jangkaan
pemerhati yang sepadan dengan kuantiti fizikal jadi dengan lebih terperinci sampler menjalankan circuit
berkali-kali pada peranti Quantum melakukan pengukuran pada setiap larian dan membina taburan kebarangkalian
daripada memulihkan rentetan bit tu semakin banyak larian atau shot yang dilakukan semakin tepat hasilnya
tapi ini memerlukan lebih masa dan Sumber Quantum yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan secara khusus ia mengira
kebarangkalian mendapatkan setiap keadaan asas standard yang mungkin dengan mengukur keadaan yang disediakan oleh circuit estimator Qiskit
menggunakan proses algebra yang kompleks untuk menganggarkan nilai jangkaan pada peranti Quantum sebenar dengan
menguraikan pemerhati kepada kombinasi pemerhati lain yang mempunyai asas eigen yang diketahui dan menjalankan di bawah
Primitives adalah teknik yang dipanggil mitigasi ralat mitigasi ralat adalah istilah umum untuk semua ini dan ia
pada asasnya merujuk kepada teknik yang membolehkan kita mengurangkan ralat circuit dengan memodelkan bunyi hingar peranti pada masa
pelaksanaan biasanya ini menghasilkan overhead pra-pemprosesan Quantum berkaitan dengan latihan model dan overhead
pasca-pemprosesan klasikal untuk mengurangkan ralat dalam hasil mentah dengan menggunakan model yang dijana tapi sebagai pertukaran untuk overhead ini
kita boleh mendapatkan hasil yang jauh lebih tepat ada berbilang teknik yang boleh kita laksanakan untuk
WEBVTT
mitigasi ralat dan kita akan bincangkan tiga daripadanya dengan lebih terperinci sedar bahawa ini adalah kawasan
penyelidikan aktif jadi teknik baru mungkin akan dicipta dan yang lama akan terus diperbaiki aras
ketahanan meningkatkan kos atau dengan kata lain masa yang diperlukan untuk jalankan kerja korang kita dah katakan bahawa pada
aras ketahanan sifar transpiler tak buat apa-apa pun pada circuit korang tapi bermula dari aras ketahanan satu ia memperkenalkan kaedah yang dipanggil twirled
readout error extinction atau kita panggil T-Rex untuk singkat twirled readout error extinction menggunakan Pauli twirling untuk
mengurangkan bunyi hingar yang merupakan sesuatu yang dah kita sentuh sebelum ini ia adalah teknik yang sangat umum dan berkesan yang
secara intuitifnya menjadikan bunyi hingar kurang tidak teratur dan lebih mudah ditangani bermula dari aras ketahanan dua kita
perkenalkan zero noise extrapolation atau ZNE untuk singkat ini adalah teknik popular yang baru-baru ni banyak
kejayaan yang kita dapat idea di sebalik ZNE mungkin agak mengejutkan kita sebenarnya tambahkan
bunyi hingar di atas apa yang dah ada tapi apa yang ini lakukan ia membolehkan kita ekstrapolasi dalam arah sebaliknya untuk
meramalkan bagaimana hasilnya jika ada bunyi hingar yang kurang ini boleh dilakukan dalam beberapa cara tertentu contohnya kita
boleh regangkan gates untuk membuatnya lebih panjang dan dengan itu lebih terdedah kepada ralat atau kita boleh jalankan lebih banyak gates yang akhirnya
menghasilkan operasi identiti jadi circuit tu tak berubah secara fungsional tapi kita dengan sengaja mensampel lebih banyak
bunyi hingar korang kena buat ni untuk setiap circuit dan setiap nilai jangkaan yang korang nak pantau jadi korang
boleh tengok macam mana ia boleh jadi sangat mahal dari segi masa yang diperlukan satu jenis ZNE tertentu dipanggil
probabilistic error amplification atau PEA untuk singkat setelah kita pelajari model bunyi hingar untuk gate PEA berfungsi dengan mensampel
ralat daripada model bunyi hingar tu dan dengan sengaja menyuntikkannya ke dalam circuit macam yang saya sebut banyak
teknik baru terus dibangunkan dan mudah-mudahan akan dilaksanakan apabila kita nampak lebih banyak muncul hanya ada satu bentuk akhir
mitigasi ralat yang saya nak bincangkan dipanggil probabilistic error cancellation bukannya berada pada aras ketahanan ketiga
PEC adalah keupayaan khas yang perlu korang hidupkan secara manual dalam Qiskit sebab sumber pengiraan
yang diperlukan untuknya tidak berskala dengan baik berbanding dengan teknik mitigasi ralat lain yang kita bincangkan korang
mula dengan belajar tentang bunyi hingar yang mempengaruhi circuit korang dengan menjalankan pembelajaran bunyi hingar atau pencirian bunyi hingar
circuits untuk setiap lapisan unik gates qubit dua yang ada dalam circuit korang hasil ini membolehkan korang menghuraikan bunyi hingar
dalam bentuk pengendali Pauli setelah korang tahu istilah bunyi hingar ni korang boleh ubahsuai circuit korang supaya
ia secara efektif mempunyai PEC bertentangan yang dibina dalam untuk membatalkan saluran bunyi hingar ini dalam beberapa cara proses ini
serupa dengan fon kepala penyahbising bunyi hingar namun cara membatalkan bunyi hingar ini sangat mahal dengan masa untuk
dijalankan yang berkembang secara eksponen dengan bilangan gates jadi mungkin bukan pilihan terbaik untuk circuit yang sangat besar kita
kini telah mencapai peringkat akhir pasca-pemprosesan pada penghujungnya kalau korang dah buat kerja yang baik dan menggunakan teknik mitigasi ralat yang betul
korang mungkin melihat jawapan akhir korang berubah seperti dalam rajah ini di sini taburan yang tidak dikurangkan
ditunjukkan dalam warna ungu adalah agak jauh dari nilai jangkaan sebenar yang ditunjukkan di sini oleh garis ini namun setelah kita terapkan mitigasi ralat
kita mendapat taburan yang dikurangkan yang ditunjukkan di sini dalam warna biru yang memuncak jauh lebih dekat dengan Nilai Sebenar sekarang
semua ini ada kosnya dan di sini kita boleh lihat bahawa varians atau lebar taburan meningkat yang
pada umumnya bukan yang korang nak tapi semua ada kosnya nasib baik kita boleh mengambil kira ini dengan menjalankan lebih banyak
shot yang menyebabkan taburan mengecil kembali ke tahap ketidaktentuan yang boleh diterima jadi tu lebih kurang semua untuk
pelajaran ni untuk kali berikutnya kita akan ambil semua langkah ni dan gabungkan dan buat kerja melalui kawasan dan contoh
kepentingan aplikasi sebenar ada beberapa perkara yang saya boleh cadangkan yang kita lakukan sehingga masa tu kalau belum lagi
pastikan korang muat turun dan sediakan Qiskit 1.0 korang juga boleh semak pelajaran berkaitan untuk bab ini dan
episod sebelumnya dalam platform pembelajaran IBM Quantum dan akhir sekali kalau korang ada minat untuk mendalami lebih lanjut dan
belajar lebih tentang teknik mitigasi ralat semak salah satu daripada banyak sumber yang saya pautkan di bawah sehingga masa tu jumpa lagi
[Muzik]